we're talking diy all week long and next
we get to
get our hands dirty and take the diy
sneaker trend that is blowing up
tick tock people are taking a pair of 15
sneakers from walmart right here and
transforming them into
painted works of art they're called
walmart's time and true platform
sneakers check these
out look at that look that's what people
are doing to them how creative
people are and here to show us how it's
done we have an incredible artist and
designer
known for her custom shoes of all kind
please welcome
jordana schrager hi jordana
here okay jordana i just want you to
know
that i am fully fangirling out on you
you have really got it going on i mean
you've designed from miley
selena gomez you've done amazing
collaborations with
uggs converse maybelline oh my goodness
like how did you get into this why are
you so amazing i want to work with you
so i actually started customizing
sneakers when i was in high school
and it was really just like a fun hobby
at the time and
now i've been doing it for over 12 years
which is so crazy
and i love using sneakers as my canvas
i feel like there's just so much to do
with them and you could have so much fun
with it
will you teach us how to do this please
yeah i want to get dirty in these paints
joanna first thing you're going to need
is white shoes
and then you're going to need some
colored paint so
these paints are leather paints they're
great for sneakers and you can wear the
shoes afterwards
all day long and just pick your favorite
color
and i'm going to section off the shoes
so
i like to start in the back and you can
see that there's a nice section
for the paint so we're going to go in
with this paint
and you can do it in any direction you
want and i would just make sure to take
it slow
and um try to stay within the lines if
possible
take it slow jordana i'm a jackrabbit i
don't know how to take
anything slow jordana who is like your
dream person to call you for a collab
i work on nikes all the time so i think
that would be really fun
i mean honestly there's so many
companies that i'd love to work with
and i think that's one of the best parts
of my job is creating like one-of-a-kind
unique designs for
a company and a collaboration you get to
create like really fun colorful designs
for a company like maybelline
and then i could do a completely
different collaboration just have to
come up with all new different designs
for them speaking of your designs
uh i think i have a design right here
would you like to tell drew what
inspired this one
so this sneaker was inspired by flowers
by drew
and i want them to just be really fun
and colorful
and i of course had to add an adorable
flower print to the sneakers
these are yes for you i get a pair these
are yours
oh my god jordana i'm so excited to have
a jordan
i love you so much thank you so
much i'm going to take a picture of
myself with them
you're showing everybody how to
self-create
be affordable express themselves and
you're inviting everyone into the party
and thank you
for all that you're putting out into the
world thank you so much well we love you
jordana and this is the beginning of a
long and beautiful friendship